when welcome to Monday evening slideshow
you see the rest find the position of a
bullet game but then I played right
before the show yeah and why did I play
me bullet game why would I do that
and all the clear reason or there is a
clear reason my usual Mouse failed on me
it doesn't do anything for recent fellow
it was really acting quite weirdly so
what did I do
as which to my super cheat notebook
mouse and I had to check if this mouse
is actually working decently it's okay
so no excuses even though I will
definitely see that as an excuse device
could should screw up totally okay I got
a request for a five-minute game on and
let's see oh we have one a gas on do I
want to have on a gas in a week against
rook click test with my notebook mouse
okay
okay welcome to all of you in the chat
got many regulars on solid vidyard
that good evening
no bullets Jim I've got a request for
five minutes out and I don't get a game
a little bit strange game started and
now we get one gets trivia night so
let's see if I can get neither three
going I was doing ok with the bullet the
forum it really wasn't all that bad it
is a bit strange but I use that mouse
regularly with my notebook I'm not
playing playing online on the notebook
just use it for me yeah for creating
chance content
like books and stuff what's going on
here
the Chilean Knight is not playing don't
tell me you've got one of those people
who lets the clock run down please
please play I don't like to resign
why can this not just be fixed here if
they don't play move in the first one
and a half minutes just I was doing
cocaine with the bullet no I was doing
okay okay with the bullet I've never
tried cocaine and you should do either I
think really widen that just change in
the survey if they don't move at let's
say for a minute you just get to win ah
that's good so we have a game okay guys
playing them the weight defense actually
this is called the base defense after
set Bop wait I think it's Bob wait um
okay I think I could be five I'd like to
take the space him he will probably go
e5 here I would assume yeah and this is
a position where white is very
comfortable
I've got the two bishops and black has
some space problems this is basically
the way I play chess give me two bishops
give me space and I will be happy
hum f5 yeah the weight as in waiting
yeah in some way it is waiting also
could have done that a little bit more
aggressively but if I just keep the
position as it is I will be slightly
better so no reason to do something
fancy
yeah yeah I think I'll take away the
light that structure does not look
healthy for black yeah what is he going
to do I can take him I think I should
probably move this of the long diagonal
so that b3 is more of an option but it
should be comfortable basically no
matter what I do cocaine might be good
for Hyper bullet it may be hyper bullet
I hope that now they have ultra bullet
as well which is 15 seconds per game
which is extremely sick I mean okay so
okay move on yeah here I can take only
five take care take only five this is
just better for white I think I'll take
let's do this how there's a question by
Viktor ex-con however here subs play the
color can how do does whole can he find
general plans in the little game plans
connected to pawn structures do I have
to buy a book
[Music]
yeah maybe book can help even though I
don't quite know what book I would
recommend for the car oh it also is just
helpful to use some gas use databases
maybe and search for typical games that
that feature ideas that you might adopt
check I would look for experts in
databases who's the biggest cairo
expert nowadays some some years ago it
would have been a taxi drea if I don't
think Trey F plays it that often anymore
yeah the Flores rios books book is
always a good bet for learning good
hidden tamarcus the answer
black did not want to put the knight on
to a8 which is probably not a troll your
night it's just a dead night then yeah
I'm covering this porn yeah it will very
likely try to advance with the king I
think he f4 is an option if he goes King
at 700 f5y oh yeah five keeps the black
King out of it and I can just bring the
king of next or even or even b5 in the
LA
black resigns yeah okay he was a in
trouble also with the time disadvantage
yeah looking through games without
comments can be tough I understand game
started the floors Rios broke many so
wide against mister what do I do here
I'll call Dakota and this this is a
really really good customer for 21 out
of 25 I don't quite remember the games
d6 okay what do you think about the wolf
start variation of the fried liver it
seems to be incorrect unfortunately will
be a cool line to play the wolf start
there is no wolf start variation of the
five debugger genes cause has and maybe
you're right yet technically but people
often call it like fried liver there as
well I understood what he meant
Tyler Spencer asked when when you won't
have em what did you study
you mean when I studied when I was still
a field master
let's touch the answer actually so
what's going on here aerco yeah my
development is not great but I've got
the two bishops which is always good
and I am NOT always good and I mean if
you meant what what what what did I do
to become an I am compared to being an
FM before and this is not so easy to say
because I'd been I wasn't FM for a
really long time but I had them the
playing strength over the national
master for most of their time but I have
simply failed to make the to make the
final nor that was necessary so I cannot
say that I did a particular thing to to
improve from FM to I am especially as
some interesting here especially as I
didn't because I didn't have didn't
stayed for very long time between 2300
and 2400 I basically went there like
within a year or so so I did not really
have this 2300 all that long but I've
been a feat of master form for for 15 16
years in typical becoming I am but that
doesn't mean that playing strength
wasn't down my my training back then in
the mid 1990s was mostly about going
through games that has always been the
thing okay
mr. yock oh he wants to put a knight on
to f4 maybe 96 even coming up
no directly okay that's who we are the
curl arm is a Georgian opening many
Georgian players played
okay so interesting to see what is doing
here my structure is a lot better
I need the knight on c3 of course the
knight on D 2 is just not well placed I
don't play that many tournaments
actually I'm of course more focused on
my matches teaching so I don't play that
much
and 25 that's interesting
I don't want to take that looks a little
bit off mmm and what I rather want him
to take and also switch the bishop to
see to what I don't see how I can do
that have to say that's a cool question
I would consider I had to play a match
against all Agathe for charity and yeah
actually I would do that
yeah if it's a good cause I would do
that even though it is a real torture
yeah how could with increment I would
play that yeah of course also probably
without increment but it's a bit
yeah I'm just a taking day for pond
maybe I can take it
nope so if I take now here is that a
good decision or not I think I would
take he will take with the F pawn item
here
probably this is this is a draw surely
this is the moment where you make a
blunder stuff when you say yeah it's
from you draw it then you blunder the
house I shouldn't blunder 93m again I
want to blunder shouldn't do that give
me again stalling us here that wouldn't
be very funny give you just crush of
course can't put this here
try to do something and what engine do I
recommend I just I just used stock fish
because it's it's for free and I don't
see I mean you can argue that maybe you
should be more flexible use Komodo as
well stuff like that but I just I think
it's it's not a huge deal time morning I
can actually take before twice yeah to
take say I am that isn't all that great
thinking about it now I can check here
that doesn't help all that much I can
bring the King up to f6 to e7
[Music]
it isn't really help unfortunately you
can go to b6
check-check
yeah I probably have to play the draw
here right can I do this it's probably a
bit risky black for fates on time I
didn't see that you were so long yeah
anyway sorry I didn't follow the Chet it
was some tough tough at the end yeah I
think Oregon's would also just use to
Gustav song probably yes but he stopped
yeah he didn't make that many mistakes
and doesn't use all that many games I
don't know yeah of course
we have jokes in German language I don't
really have a good no no I'm good at
telling any why does Joanie have so many
I am the geums but no player above 2700
M
yeah I think them it's probably a matter
of how attractive it is in Germany to
become a purely chain laying started
professional who is that subhana what we
are very high rated that's Slovenia
actually that is Slovenia okay
and yeah I think in Germany probably
becoming a purely professional player
it's not attractive to many too many
people even promising players like let's
every bomb I don't think is a
professional and we've seen a doorman
that is good friendly or potential he
still doesn't studies I did some I mean
I'm not saying this is this is bad that
he's doing it's just that if you have
this kind of attitude you're not going
to become a world-class player you just
have to be a fully focused on playing
the job this is a very very
unconventional game
grah offered really yeah gain support on
sir
yeah I said I have to go you know here
and yeah I mean okay it's nine points
and I don't really like to play against
us
okay so new game it's a bit of games not
versed on it it's okay
how many 1957 it's not no name on
average how many lessons do I do with
the same student the week who okay um
yeah I don't know one one hour a week is
probably average it depends I've got
also various levels let sale of
student-teacher relationship there are
also some students who really like that
they don't want to do it so regularly so
we just meet on special on occasions
when we say when we say let's say that's
prepare certain opening or prepare
certain um a certain position time or so
Kings gambit with it I should play the
Kings gambit you say we'll see I can try
I can play a little bit of beef or
corset that I can definitely do and see
what happens interesting c5 looks this
timing looks a little bit
looks a little bit strange
yeah the ship cakes should be nice for
me you know that is benefit the ante
Anthony I was thinking night a four
words I'm not sure if d-force may be an
option for him I will do that though
Tyler Spencer asked if I'm accepting new
students generally I do it it's not so
easy to find open timeslot section I'm
happy to answer your detailed questions
you can go into my website just explain
comment send me a message e then you can
see what we can do if we find a common
time and everything okay so let's have a
look here 95 is a move that looks
annoying here
absolutely it's made them letters made
like this position so much I can't go
age for him hmm
maybe maybe there was a forum as Marcus
urges okay Bishop he Aryan I don't like
my position to be perfectly honest I
already don't like it maybe I should
have played Queen to f3m
yeah and now I'm definitely going there
okay but isn't this I don't really have
a good continuation I wanted to do this
yeah anyway but it doesn't really do
much
III is bad hmm
it's not easy him
yeah Nakamura is doing live streams now
yeah I heard about that at the pen yeah
I didn't watch I didn't watch didn't
watch that maybe I will check it out so
I think this is maybe better for black
but not totally sure what what is
planners no I understand he wants to use
this this is some dangerous of course my
back rank and so n stuff
hmm a mouse is acting in a weird way
right okay Bishop c1
yeah medicinal good yeah it was not good
yeah he's also it seems that black is
not finding something totally convincing
this night is still pinned right it's
their tactic and I will see a tag tag
try to bring the night to D 3 or 2 C
form Queen d7 Maria my trust to put look
on to have six definitely makes sense
about the tradition
oh my god does a snitch good time
warning now I'm totally lost him very
nice game my black mother good gamer me
but he did a good job I think
that's probably some kind of some kind
of logout at least can you continue so
moment still ah ah no Kuni every friggin
I would have liked to fight a little bit
at least and now I cannot even fight
yeah it's bad Dave I'll feed you learn
the hidden area he deserved to win
definitely but I cannot do him much
promise to lost totally lost though I
did I play that that I will play badly
probably this night a for business was
wrong does this stuff here that was
probably something was wrong their game
started at fight that day part of the
game I really played badly got into real
trouble on with the opening okay so
let's see if I can get this automatic
check maiden as soon as it happens
people play this song I do they do they
actually now know that they are getting
it with that with a detective you really
get that played more in then recent ones
I should take
forgot to take on now you get this no
this is weird actually 95 first is what
they do
I don't want to trade now I really don't
read it's okay for me but I would like
to move the night and rather play for f5
and this pollution and I don't see that
this I don't think it's possible
okay so let's play normal stuff sorry
huh
so he allows me to play ninety seven and
dispersion I am NOT f5s they're fighters
sorry Harper threat y'all in-page us do
I have favorite TV shows I haven't
really been known looking into him into
TV shows that much since I became
professional chess teacher I tend to
work so much that and I mean enjoyable
work then I really don't watch much TV I
mean I watch absolutely no one let's say
regularly like German TV because it's
just completely unbearable but I did
watch while it was a bad move actually
check and now it's got deform it's
probably probably okay fun yeah
probably not a disaster but still but I
mean there are really good US shows or
British shows so I've watched a bit some
years ago the things that were popular
back then and that I liked like breaking
bad or Dexter things like that
I did not didn't watch Game of Thrones
and maybe I should should try that but
the general likes enters the candle
setting is not not usually my cup of tea
yeah so what is he doing it I was
expecting default but somehow he's not
playing it I don't know maybe he's got
some I always got bad connection bad
connection
maybe I'm winning this one by this
connection is shown on the white side
what is that Brad Pitt fighting zombies
what what what movie is that it's
supposed to be on German TV I think I
heard about that his Bishop on h7 yeah
it was more like four fixed into his
connection there to gain the tempo and
then go d4 I think the form then 97 back
it's a really really weird queer thing
tough world was that hair I heard about
that
Jaclyn Smith asks how to Texas work when
working over the Internet
oh you don't want to know my my account
and is doing everything
we I just pay the normal let's say
German Texas yeah bit of a slow session
yeah it takes a while to get opponents
what I gas is actually on and playing so
I could I could get that pairing got
some good guys on Goldman displaying and
I advice on Eva didn't know how she's
got a really high rating I again started
flopper let's play proper b3 okay I'm
using a desktop yes Knight to b3
I can take maybe Jordan page asks do you
believe that everybody has a rating
ceiling check that some people no matter
I've developed will never get above a
certain point yes I believe that that's
absolutely true
so here we have a pretty open position I
inserted the check to make him play some
sort of committal move like c3 let's see
how flopper is handling that yes so it's
close maybe I should just do this for 95
95 and make some pressure you cannot
castle you know so um what about this
Queen f6 to h6 maybe many many possible
ideas
I don't think so
Jorge's page asks me if I could hit 2600
if I work with you really hard and my
answer is very unlikely I think rather
no is appropriate
like who my current rating is 2440 and I
think I could probably get to somewhat
Bend up somewhat above to five but to
six is really really hard really really
hard I mean I've never played a plate
like one or two tournaments in my life
where I hit this kind of performance and
I think it's really really tough yeah
this position is really lucky I think I
just go away five I have pieces for the
kingside but he just careful queenside
which is funny
I don't think this is that bad but he
can play like a three-hit chief or stuff
so let's see I cannot take and no and
did those those performances weren't GM
norms because one was just a five round
event the European Club Cup and and I
also hit this kind of performance once
when I am wonder state championships but
there were no grandmasters playing so it
was a really nice performance but there
were no GM's nowadays I think one one
one is the Grandmaster of those cars but
at the time no yeah this looks really
really wacky but I I don't I do have
some ideas or at least
I don't know the Queen isn't so bad now
here right I'm looking at this okay so
what is 95 doing I'm not sure I think I
have to do this anyway
and now yeah one thing is with this
thing what kind of playing strength can
you hit and so on I actually enjoy
teaching more than playing to be honest
so when I don't really want to play all
that much so what to do here I can take
on these 500 as a weird move the knight
is only active P so this is right so it
looks weird
I can definitely just take g5 like
Wynette fun but it's okay and here the
night is hain first so he's got his
going F for problem
yeah this is good for black but I was
hoping for more any of my students
coming to reach 2600 that's a funny
question and if I don't think so
actually I'm happy whether oh oh that's
a good move by flopper can I do this
keeping everything attacked I didn't see
that beforehand of course I think it
works which is pure luck check ok so
what's going on here
I just have to gamble him play quickly
hope for the best
wait Knight f5 Knight f5 just around the
corner Wow not good you can just take c7
actually that doesn't help still sucks
time morning
so remarkably bad position the worst
thing is it's so easy for him to play
this position
super easy to play just playing this
really well
check check check check check
[Music]
checking drop so we just escaped at all
okay
man it was weird game weird from start
to finish and probably pretty awful okay
let's go 14k ahh
oh my goodness we were both probably in
good shape at some point where it really
didn't really do well down yeah this
this is certainly good for black coming
but I didn't do it right game started
Mara anguish my mind is broken I don't
know who that is
by the way Oh Jack I'm currently working
a bit on this open
and I don't really know it I think they
go g5 they're quite quite often I'd
early
mara English the Narrow Sea
mother is the seer anguish yeah I didn't
get didn't get only Gus
oh oh whoa whoa I just blundered you for
that's not good anyway have to give the
GM some sort of headstone otherwise it's
not it's not entertaining enough
probably yes and he doesn't take you for
even like this even more but okay let me
keep the default Condon not sure that
this was really better I mean my men
development is not that bad if I get
Bishop C 292 d4 I am okay
hmm
not great our English means seal the
snake okay
okay so he's looking at this pawn there
on c3 so on page I've have I'll read my
great predecessors yeah I've got the
books and I cannot say that I've read
them all that would be pretty em pretty
tough here it's it's it's a lot it's
lots of stuff but I've read most of it
even though from the Chesham history
point of view err I was reasonably well
wet before I got the book so in many
cases I didn't really learn anything
substantially new but I think it's it's
a really good starting point to get an
overview of chat history so I recommend
those books usually they have I mean
there are also bad points about them but
most of it is good so interesting his
pawn structure isn't great but he's got
the bishop BAM
that's interesting
if I can rearrange my pieces properly I
think I'm quite okay Bishop 123
[Music]
getting the King to - is he going f5v on
this position maybe but the 95 no no no
okay f5 is not a problem
yeah it's funnier that Magnus Carlton is
playing in the World Cup that's an
interesting that's interesting him I
mean he always stated that he likes
knockout tournament so there is
definitely some logic to that that he's
playing okay and now we are getting
somewhere because the bishop on d7 is
just not a good piece
hey I think like a slowly but surely
going to be pushed back here it's not
really a good position it's going here
one wook comes to c3 or Knight to b3 and
he will do c5 I don't even need to put
rook on to c3 f5 s f3 and over now he
had to do something really on now black
is toast just wins d file that that's
Maisie of the snake as you see on the
mania so we learned cool things in these
live streams so on Knight B 3 wants to
go b6 I guess
don't think that this helps in much I
once you get into opposite colored
bishops ah interesting
hmm okay and then I have to do it
differently this is going to be very
nice compensation for the exchange I
actually think you will probably try to
return it as soon as possible
maybe you will just second c-5m good
anyway
what comes to f1 that that black is
completely toast yet my man I Ted Bishop
are so much stronger than his pieces
this rope didn't give F squares so let's
see
check maybe is just such a nice thing
now oh I didn't think about that
where is to where the a pawn is kind of
dangerous
time warning check check
black resigns I came upon I don't know
maybe I was overestimating this but I
thought he really had a bad position
after they exchanged second okay let's
go for any game and see who's Kelly next
one autograph game maybe it is not only
more confortable yeah I was actually
thinking of playing a tournament in the
u.s. yeah the world opened something
like that I don't have a concrete plan
for that but it's something I have on
the radar yeah one more game game
started and it's miracle okay no don't
get don't get a bank oh the trumpeters I
think I go Queen b6 e oil 5b 3 that
looks bad I mean really
b3 you give up your dark squared Bishop
and then you play d3 that looks weird
really really weird
maybe night to be forum kinda Spencer as
how much time do I put into my own chest
studies that's easy basically zero
something of time Philip operas if I saw
magnets Carla's girlfriend no who is
that she good-looking have no idea
didn't see it didn't see her I didn't
see the news I mean ok interesting yeah
I mean the chick looks very obvious
check let's check d5 is hanging actually
so if I go here and how does it cover it
I mean I can take that
let's take it
hmm 3 2 G for some he's trying to take
this I can check this with check here
right check Electra not really be bad
[Music]
kind of irritating the exposition but I
can just go back right or do I have
something better and b6 queen takes
Bishop f5 maybe I mean 96 that's really
lucky stuff I just go back mangos posted
a picture on facebook okay then I'm not
going to see it I just I know I'm
running into this frigging fork there's
a fork on c3 this is this is this is
stupid
what did I do here that's really stupid
ah if winning winning after move seven
year and then you get into this sister
fear and I'm so stupid sometimes I
didn't see that the bishop is hanging
96 94 bishop a couple of 1996 I'm
touchin [ __ ] and this is spoiling the
whole session yet this crappy game when
you like winner to move 5 yeah yeah at
night know what the big is saying of
course it was especially considering
that that black was probably winning
with every suit every single normal move
as this was completely unplayable stuff
for white check check and now he gets
the Queen stratagem hmm servile design
in white click the beginning of that
game so terribly you never know what you
will do check
Jen I don't have enough material here
not not even close
even though ya know I never played any
other strategy game in any hi morning
serious way the only thing that I try to
program which is not really a strategy
game tell some strategic elements good
did I go into f4 here check that's
actually pretty and I said so easy I am
probably
please seven coming and made on one
channel okay
black resigns these are always the most
restraining games they're like yeah you
have to move five or so you're
strategically winning sb3 is really
complete nonsense yeah I mean dear black
is just winning and check until this is
this is basically resign herbal check
yeah I can do whatever you just not the
move that I played I mean just this is
so idiotic you go here and white resigns
the game it's just completely over okay
anyway let that cost some point yeah
I've actually lost point in that session
anyway I hope you enjoyed the show I'll
be back next Monday that is the 31st
right yeah next Monday the usual time
usual place again hope you enjoy it
thanks for also being active in the chat
bye-bye
you